now according russia has sentenced
jailed kremlin critic alexi navalny to
nine years in prison he was found guilty
of fraud and contempt of court the
opposition figure says the charges are
politically motivated navalny is already
serving a two and a half year sentence
let's go straight away to brandon smith
who's live for us in moscow and bernie
the verdict is no surprise and now and
the velni out of active politics for
years to come i guess
nick no no surprise not only is alexi
navalny sentenced to nine years in
prison on top of the two and a half
years he was already sentenced to last
year he will serve that sentence this
new sentence in a maximum security
prison the prosecutors had asked him to
be moved from the
relatively less severe penal colony he's
in now
to a maximum security prison it silences
effectively the last
known open political opponent to
vladimir putin in
russia he had also navali managed during
his time in prison to get messages
through his lawyers
and posted those on instagram but
instagram is now been banned in russia
blocked in russia so even if you wanted
to you can't read anything about navalny
there either and we understand also that
lawyers who are going to speak to
journalists outside the prison to
comment after the sentencing they have
been detained
and driven away in a van before they
were able to speak
to journalists
anyway what's happened to navalny is
unlikely to get any coverage at all on
russian state-controlled television he's
he's not really known or heard or known
about by people here
since he returned from germany almost a
year ago now he'd been poisoned uh with
a nerve agent
on a flight from siberia he was taken to
russia to germany for medical treatment
and recovered and flew back in january
last year arrested as soon as he landed
and since then has been in jail has not
been outside of jail and now
really it's unlikely you're going to
hear anything at all from alexei navalny
for the nine years he's in prison all
right bona thanks for that bernie smith
in moscow let's take this on we can
speak now to rasmus nielsen who's a
lecturer at the ucl school of slavonic
and east european studies joining us
live now from uh london so sir what's
your reaction to this uh they'll need
nine years in a maximum security prison
what do you think the implications are
yeah i mean as you are as your reporter
and the previous guest
this is no surprise at all um i think
the implications are or certainly the
intents behind this are twofold on the
one hand um the russian state wants to
silence the money and make sure that he
stays out of the political process and
also stays unable to
promote any sort of any part of his
calls promo send out any messages and so
on
um more broadly of course this is
another step in the russian regime's
attempt to silence all criticism within
the country and basically to attack what
putin effectively has called
fifth columnists as in traders inside
russia i mean there's been some
oh i think we've lost uh our audio
connection with rasmussen
i think let's see is he back or can you
hear us sir
hello can you hear me now i can hear you
so we lost you just for a second there i
was just going to say despite
being behind bars alexia navalny has
managed to to call for protests is that
likely to continue in any way
um i think protest will continue to some
extent not necessarily because he called
for it but because there is a genuine um
quite significant group of people in
russia who are protesting against the
war and against what the regime is doing
right now inside russia i fear however
that repression from the regime will
only increase
to what degree do you think this will
stoke anti-putin sentiment in russia
this sentence as you say we've been
discussing it it hasn't come as a
surprise
but and there will be those who support
this verdict and sentencing
yeah i'm sorry we've lost uh our guest
there we've lost our connection with
rasmus nielsen so we'll move on